[音楽]
[拍手]
こちら河野そこです
うちはあるの代表をしています
あるわ
環保氏らので夜明けという意味です
1日の始まりに
感じる
希望やエネルギー
それを起業家が新しい社会をつくっていくという希望やエネルギーと
朝食合わせています
あるのビジョンは
地球上のどこに生まれた人も
ひとりひとりの才能を発揮できる社会を
あるはアジアで
インコ環境
教育
医療などの
社会課題の
解決に取り組むビジネス
起業家への投資を行っています
私たちはこれを社会的投資と呼んでいます
お金儲けや
在的なギターだけを求めるのでなく社会課題と解決
つまり社会的リターンを同時に2位9しているからです
私は
両親がクリスチャンの家庭で生まれました
聖書や教会は子供の頃からとても身近なものでした
中学生の時
学校に
ネパールで医療活動をしている
岩村ゴール先生という方がいらっしゃいました
perl の山奥で診療上開き
そこに肥土山のふた山も
1週間 ak
通ってくる歩いてくる
結核に患者さんの話
現地の人たちと一緒に食べる
ご飯おいしいこと
子どもたちが現地の子どもたちと一緒に遊ぶ話
どれも手を取る
話でした
私は大人になったら
彼のような浴衣がすごいなと
思いました
あ一応を卒業して1995デー
ネパールではなくてカンボジアに赴任しました
そしてる需要や誰かを
通して
カンボジアの
復興
開発の支援をする仕事を
そこでの
企業がとの出会いから社会的投資を始めることになりました
当時の
私が確認した当時の監護者は
長く続いた内戦の影響でとても傷ついていました
建物の
銃弾方があったり
道路の真ん中に大きなが
間もだったり
また内政が終わった時には医者が50人しか食っていなかったと言われるように
人材も不足していました
人々も少し終わって
自信を失っているようでした
僕たちやっぱりがんぼちゃせんだから
ダメじゃないかなぁ
そんなセリフを何度いきました
でも驚くほどのスピードでカンフーじゃこうしていきました
経済発展
10代20代の若者たちは
明るい表情して今日より明日は必ず良くなる
そう考えていましたイェイ
私の仕事
感冒ちゃんを復興開発を
悦合うという仕事はとてもやりがいのある仕事でした
でも同時に
遠藤土台にして
それを拡大して
いくはずな伸び
援助が終わるとプロジェクトも終わって人は散り散りバラバラになり
活動もなくなってしまう
そんな状況に
これをが空いたバイカー
何とかしたいと思うようになりました
カンボジャ人
援助に頼らず
自分たちの力で
続的な社会をつくっていくんだそういうようになっていました
私は社会課題の解決は
ビジネスでもできるんだということ
カンボジアで知りました
カンボジアだけでなくインドでも投資をしています
テクノロジーを使って競争に両サービスを届ける事業
地下水の性物質を除去するシステムをつくって
農村の人たちに手頃な値段で安全な水を届ける人
この写真は
ちょっと見にくいかもしれませんが
農村にあるミルクのコレクションセンターです
これは iot を使って酪農セクターを開拓しよう
という授業です
どうかがいい
浅羽ミルクを絞って
一例と2 l 6 l
それぐらいなんですけどこうやってセンターになってきます
以前は
水を混ぜる人がいたり
値段が
まちまちだったり支払いが遅れたりしていました
ここにあるような機器を入れてその場で
品質や量を測定してそれに見合った価格が支払われるようになると
農家の人たちもそれにありますあるのでああ
良い品質とミルクを持ってくるように偽造は出ない海なり
またこのデータがクラウドで
送られて
コントロールすることが
できません
今5000カ所へ調
登録のは農家は100人以上になっています
今でもまだ
銀宝の1月の初10%は代走に住んでいると言われています
この淫行の本倍の解決を
濃紺の人たちの円形収入の
別の機械農業以外の機会は作ることで解決しようという企業かもな
都市では
2000万円以上の人が
8労働者を必要としているのです
そこに注目して女性と
家事労働者を必要としている人の間のマッチングサービスを
か
ました
このサービスデー
女性たちの収入は3割から5割アップしました
雇用する人たちは医療サービスを受けられて喜ぶようになり
働く人たちにとっては
契約書の作成を穴だったり
24時間 l プライを設けたり
は第二次宿泊地所一時の宿泊所を提供したり
そういったことで
労働者の安全が守られて
そして
いよいよ農環境で働けるように
そういう配慮しています
そんな
様々な
授業が
あります
企業型でアウト
僕はッ
心躍るような
そんな時間ですっ
でも授業は山へ
歓迎
気ばかりではありません
失敗もありました
あと授業は
投資してももなく
経営が果たして
資金繰りが厳しくなりました
あの体この手を尽くして色々なアドバイスもん
したつもりですが
起業家は全くいうことを
いきません
耳を貸しません
その起業家は
社会起業家としてはとても夢で評判も良かったです
南米
悪いことに私たちが投資判断だときに使った資料には
誤りがあって
そして投資したお金は
使う目的違う目的に使われてしまっていました
ランド胸がは話し合いを傘が重ねますか
企業がどうも
通し方もええ
開く投資家は言いましたが
起業家を甘やかしてはいけない
厳しく
鳥食べるべきだ
また別の投資家は言いました
社会的投資なんだから
in blue ん
はするべきではない
どうしたらいいでしょ
なんか6何度も交渉して
ある日
私は言いました
起業家彼がいい
何をするべきか
カロリー
彼がわかることができるよう
ああああああ
泥を
彼の対応は
驚くように変わりましたそれまでの自分の人ばかりを
繰り返すではなくて私たちを信頼してくれるようになったのです
長い年月がたくて
彼はある会社に就職しました
その会社の社長に
信頼されて源氏のプロジェクトを任されています
その彼から
その佐藤から連絡がありました
そして私に会いたいというのです
あって
謝罪したいと
ました
私は2人に会いました
とても嬉しかったです
まだお金は
帰ってきてないんですけど
でも
彼がその失敗の経験を来なかったことにするのではなくて
それを
今抜かしているんだなぁ
そう感じたからですよ
その経験は私たちにとっては
とても
閉会出来事でした
失ったものも
たくさんあります
同時に私たちは即ぱら多くのことを
教えてもらいました
投資と予防の国家さ
企業が僕の
お金の力
人間の弱さと強さ強かっ
その両方
私たちは
学んだのです
人間は
弱いものではないでしょうか
でもその
弱さの中にへ
アブ強さと桜
tomoya いうとき
私たちの中にある
可能性が
引き出されていく
そう私は
信じています
起業家が
共に歩んでいる人たちも貧しい人たち
弱さを抱えた人立つかもしれません
でも
起業家はその人達の中にある大きな
力を信じて
その可能性を引き出す
手助けを
しているのではないかなと
思います
聖書の中にこんな一節があります
ところが主が言われた
私の恵みはあなたに対して十分である
たちの力は
弱い完全に現れる
社会的投資の醍醐味
それは
社会問題解決という難しい課題に
ビジネスで取り組もうとしている
志の高い
アイデアにあふれた
実行力のある
個性豊かな
おっ
面白い費用が経つと出会っていっ
そして彼らと共にビジョンを語る
授業がたり
共に授業をつくっていく
授業を通して社会をよくしていく
その戸田す怪我
できることだと思います
企業がは
とても面白い人たちで
それはとても
楽しい
仕事でもあります
何が起きるか分からない
ハラハラドキドキ
面白い
毎日でもあります
私たちは皆
この命をよく生きる
この社会をよくする
可能性を
持っていると思います
私たちの隠されたあ
可能性を引き出すために
共に
歩もうではありませんか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
ああああああ
ん